waited months sometimes half a year for
certain items during the pandemics so
what's in store for us now given the
situation in russia ukraine and china
one expert tells us we are in for even
more shipping gridlock
yani mazur is the cgo of gatita a
technology company that consults with
third party amazon sellers 80 percent of
whom experienced global supply chain
issues in the past year dreading the
impacts of the ongoing war with russia
and ukraine ukraine a major supplier of
raw materials crucial for microchips a
lot of the cables you know these wiring
for electronics is actually a source of
these raw materials from ukraine but i
think also palladium and nickel which is
also critical for the production of
microchips what's more the current
lockdowns to contain the spread of covet
in key cities of china important
production centers for electronic
components could severely squeeze the
supply of laptops mobile phones tvs and
cars a quarantine mandate extended in
shanghai may cause supply chain
disruptions far greater than last year's
partial closures of ports that is going
to affect all these manufacturing
facilities in that region
and that is going to throw probably
another wrench into inflation because
once again vendors who are getting their
supplies from from those factories will
not get get it on time or might not even
get it all there is some good news third
party sellers who got their products
late last year are sitting on inventory
right now so if you're thinking of
christmas shopping in april might be
overstocked so it shouldn't be as hard
for consumers to get what they need and
at a better price